hello and welcome to this video I am
providence and Jean Bryant am I right
there yep okay so going for main line
we're going to test the brayer I guess
no and I would have played again the
Chigi ring it's just out of just out of
habit okay
and only play nazi for first hey it
could easily be a difference there nie
bede to now maybe mmm-hmm okay that's a
bit too quickly player
okay I go back it's not think about this
for too long sometimes taking is an idea
okay i just go d5 and see what he does
them d 50 yeah my position is a bit bit
cheeky here and take d for would like to
but doesn't work take d for it takes f6
again takes you five that's the problem
can just take that and I don't see how I
get the porn back
now maybe be four nights knight c6 with
the double attack and double the taking
p for end there I thought I can go but I
probably cannot I thought I can take you
five at the end but I i know i only get
that look there that's not enough
is going six of course 594 but the pawn
on d6 is pretty big 93 though I he has
to take care about that let's just
create c3 here I don't see how I get get
my pawn bag
trying to get f5 and will be difficult
oh it takes it surprising didn't didn't
expect that at all maybe not so bad it
just I didn't expect to move one bit
okay if I've night before is good okay
magicka okay I can just take the thing
oh my god oh now I have to stop that
session ha i really have to if i'm not
seeing this stuff oh my god the game was
already pretty bad anyway this is this
is just the icing on the cake oh my god
ah just rupee 8
they're just be five wins of course
everything but now anyway
sticking quite a bit ub5 Bishop c5
that's a nice little cheapo but it
didn't fell for ok so far is probably
not helping can I do this I just got b6
has to do that come on if he takes with
the rook Bishop c5 for Queen g3 that at
least some kind of trick or wiggles and
he just advances I know Bishop c5 looks
kind of interesting
there's still some something left here
that I can do so is giving material now
I don't light a seven or I don't know I
mean ok cannot go to the six I cannot go
to e7 that looks scary
cream back time morning you just
promotes I think the night of seven at
the end check check yeah I'm very nicely
played at the end Tector claimant
killing me check yep okay just push up
pushes my food stuff home it did felt
like he was allowing stuff somehow but
the bones are just too strong it's a
very convincing way to end things yeah I
just I just I had a completely off game
here just to just bad the the whole mess
starts think around here with ya with me
allowing this this is just bad bad for
black I don't get that back so now it
just it's just a bad position don't know
I guess he played that very convincingly
I wasn't so sure about it during the
game but yeah he just he just killed me
very convincingly okay thanks for
watching